[Music]
natalie thompson
i know you've already been asked but for
the sake of the camera you sure you
don't want legal representation i don't
need it i can tell you that you've been
arrested on suspicion of conspiracy to
abduct leo newman
nope there's obviously been some sort of
misunderstanding can't be certain
whether this is terrorist related
politically motivated or simple
extortion
young guy leo newman gets packed into a
suitcase by a masked dad
nypd flags four suspects
catherine newman i cannot imagine what
you're going through at the moment i
love my son
and i want him back
we're being set up
by us
i don't know why
what do we have in common we're all
british
and we're all in new york on the daily
only among us
do we look like kidnappers do you what
does a kidnapper look like
you
without any proof or innocence the
damage is already done
i can fix this
are you sure you know what you're doing
no i can't go back nobody buys me as a
mother
i'll always be a ceo first
plate long there's no other option
first page in the playbook except i
don't remember the chapter on the kidnap
of your only child
[Music]
you're being asked to communicate in
order to free your lonely child these
people want you to tell the truth we're
getting deeper in there is still a
chance that people may understand
everything you've done until now
you have underestimated these people
right from the beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
the truth will come out
[Music]
[Music]
you